so West I want to start with you because
the one of the in the introduction that
great opening that Tom Wilkinson says
where he talks about what people think
screenwriters do if they're just writing
all day and things were coming up so I
did that spoke to me about inspiration
so I kind of want to just ask you about
inspiration and bringing this story
together I know that Stephan spied was
the story was inspired by some of his
writings so can you give us a little bit
of that yes well you know the the from
Vigo something who I'd never read until
quite recently like five years ago
something like that and I loved these I
love these books and he's a you know I
fell in love with this writer and the
movie is not based on any book any
particular story but it's sort of me
trying to do one of his things I guess
and and this introduction that you refer
to is one of the most that is that
really is lifted directly from this book
beware of pity which begins with with
with a sort of introduction from the
from the quote-unquote author like an
author character and so yes that was
that's a you know I mean I don't even
know if I agree I mean III don't haven't
particularly experienced what he said
you know he says that people bring the
stories to you when they know you're a
writer I've haven't particularly found
that but um but I like that I like that
you know I like the idea of it I'd like
to say it sort of sets the stage and in
fact I kind of question I I sort of man
I'm not so sure if I experienced that
yeah I I think he's the kind of writer
who would would use it as a tool for
telling his story
Minoo a sort of idea like that so I know
that you started this story came with
you collaborated with a Hugo Guinness
and story and then you went off and and
wrote the screenplay for it so we
started a bit with we have a Hugo and I
are all very old friends longtime press
and we have a mutual friend who was one
of the
models for this character the miss this
is one of those ways it's a big ensemble
but it is there is this one guy who's
the center of the movie it's really on
his shoulders and he's got to somebody
with him you know zero that part we
wrote with Rafe in mind in the hopes
that he would want to do it and and I
don't really I you know it's not like
there's a second there I don't know who
the second choice could even be it's
it's a it's a it's a hard part and it
you know it took to cast and he was the
perfect one and the only one all the
other parts were we just finished the
script and and I started you know we
figured it out afterwards this came with
quite a funny approach which was like
Wes says the array of here's a script
I'd like you to read please let me know
what part you would like to play I read
the script and there's this great park
or good stuff and I think am I allowed
to say I'd like to play good stuff there
were there was a little bit of back back
and forth and then then it was very Wes
was more overt and so I want you to play
Gustav and then I said okay I'll play
seems like such a great role to because
monsieur gustave he had so many layers
to him so I could just imagine that as
an actor that gives you so many choices
this is a great part is a great part on
the page in for all the reasons you're
saying you know and and one of the
things with a with a part when you
clearly on the page it's got all kinds
of possible interpretations or potential
and on the first things that I asked was
where do we where is what's the nuance
what's the tone of Gustav because
clearly it it could lend itself to sort
of high definition flamboyancy /
camporee and what was it you know where
did it lie and whether one of our first
earliest meetings was to read through it
and Wes was quick to sort of identify
that whenever he must jump in
because it was it seemed to me that you
didn't want it to become overtly
affected he needed to be rooted in of
when it when it when it's when you seem
to identify when you said we read one
yes when it's sort of more you yes yeah
well you know that that's the thing
because the character you well you know
we know I mean I've seen I've you don't
waste sitting in the editing room I know
all that you did this performance I know
all the performance you give in the
movie the performance you gave you know
all the other takes and it's not you you
know it's a it's a it's a it's a
creation but but the thing that I felt
just when when I first saw you starting
to do it was it was that you could make
him a real person you know and that was
the that that's to me that's really all
we want I mean you you talk very fast
and there's a there's great precision
and in his way of in his physicality and
and that's all part of his character but
to me I just felt like he's he's alive
now and that's the thing you hope for
and that's that collaboration between
the act or the director yeah so I'm
gonna talk about the look of the film
because this it's it's it's a very
intricate story and it's very broad and
it's very big so I'm gonna talk to Adam
about working with the team to create
the look of the film and and and finding
the town the zubur often and and where
is the budapest hotel where is the grand
budapest hotel where is it like where
did we where do we know we were at I'm
still not good on the pronunciation good
girl it's I think is the official this
wonderful little town with all this
still standing architecture from the
15th and 16th centuries I'm is a really
beautiful perfect little spot and and
that that kind of became our town and
then there was a department store in the
in the middle of the town that was
really the key to the whole thing that
that Wes had scouted and found I think
was was it your first trip I wasn't even
along on this trip this way at the very
very very beginning well you were I
think you were in
New Orleans is only 12 years of slave
yeah well we were in Germany right yeah
and yeah we and I was trying to keep
track of the scouting and it was like
Schloss well and you know when you
haven't been to any of these places
they're really confusing yeah and so I'm
trying to spreadsheets going trying to
just track where you were going and
we're saying there were a lot of Sh
losses but but the the department store
was kind of the key to the whole thing I
think and and you know Department this
department store is a you know Art
Nouveau star you you you you can steal
as we learned it was called dirt kind of
turned at the center too in 1910 or
something like that right there and this
great building and that and that was
what what drew us to that town because
we couldn't find a real hotel that was
right you know we couldn't find the
hotel where we could just do it wait I
had sort of thought well we're gonna in
Switzerland somewhere we're gonna find
this place and it's gonna somewhere and
we just never did we just we got lots of
ideas travelling around but we never
found the place and this and then this
department store sort of started to
suggest a way we could do it and and and
then along with that the whole little
city of Garlits that's half in Germany
and half in Poland and 22 minutes from
Czech Republic it's exactly where our
imaginary place ought to be and it was
great and in fact Rayford i Rayford
actually made a movie and in Garlits the
the parts of the reader were filmed in
in garlotte's it's i mean it's quite a
popular movie location at the moment it
didn't um The Book Thief came in after
us monuments men came in after us
yeah it says whoring around yeah it's a
bit cheap yeah they're actually talking
about putting letters on the hill
outside of town
you know the brewery huh well I know
that the you know we were even forced
out we we left a day early because of
the thief yeah they forced us out of our
little plots
so another another another device in
telling this story I thought was really
great was the use of the dollhouse and
the animatics and all those all those
great devices and in telling his story
so who did you work with to create all
that that there's a huge team and
involved in that I mean we we designed
them and drew them and and and and built
them at the studio kind of concurrently
with the filming and then Jeremy Dawson
is hiding out here somewhere he's waving
in the back was was kind of the the kind
of key central person I'm bringing
everything together with shooting those
and then and then integrating them after
into the end of the end of the film but
they were built they were built in a
workshop right next to the workshop
building the full-scale scenery and it
all happened it all happened right along
in the same time frame the other thing I
wanted to mention as well and talked
about is another creative device is
using the different aspect ratios talked
to about you know the work you do Robert
yeoman in creating that and why and what
did that do for you and in your
storytelling as a filmmaker I I'd always
wanted to do a shoot a movie in the
Academy ratio so this was a chance to do
rip almost the whole movie in that way
but to frame it with some widescreen
scenes and kind of make our different
time periods that way and it used to be
thinking I will would occasionally I'd
say with the different movies over the
years I've thought I would like to try
try to do a movie in the in the end you
know one three three or one three seven
or whatever it is and we'd find out you
know there's really no way to get the
theaters to put enough theaters to pray
they have to change the gate and it
lends or who knows what now it's digital
and you can sort of just do it to how
you want and somebody presses a button
then it just plays about the editing
process because this is there are a lot
of intricate pieces with chases and you
know chases through the steel is what I
thought is really terrific and that
great escape out of the prison so talk
about the work that you know once you
had all this village you go into editing
room how did you put this story together
also with those three music
incorporating those three aspect ratios
we
while we're shooting we might edit a
will edit on the weekend a bit and do a
few scenes but we don't do an assembly
you know we don't we just sort of start
and we just go one scene at a time
through the whole movie and most of it
is edit in most of it we haven't really
touched it until the movies all finished
and we're in there and but with the move
like this you know the first cut of the
movie this is a happen with a few of
these things um the first cut is like
you know 87 minutes or something I mean
we've cut it very very tight and then we
slowly kind of put things back which is
usually which is kind of the opposite of
the way I think it's more common and
then we usually end up looking at that
and it's sort of work but we find a
bunch of problems and then we spend
months and months doing millions of
little bitty things and kind of finding
another layer of sort of devices to help
just make things more clear and it's
usually it's usually a lot of stuff
especially now that there's so much
digital there are so many options of how
to do things and how to how to polish it
you know there's just hundreds and
hundreds of things on there that you
probably wouldn't think you would even
bother to do digitally but you know we
can we do